the editor-in-chief of daily wire.com is
opposed to the ben shapiro show so guess
his name which is the top conservative
podcast in the nation he is the author
of seven books and he has been a
nationally syndicated columnist since
the age of 17
pity he got such a late start he's a
graduate of UCLA and Harvard Law School
please welcome Ben Shapiro so we have a
lot to get into here and there are areas
of agreement I made many of you know who
these two guys are and you know you can
imagine the force we're gonna chart here
I want to start with Ben he's had a
truly unusual experience and then many
of you may not be aware of just how
unusual and this will take those into
areas of agreement Ben where you know we
definitely agree which is around the
primacy of free speech and how strange
our national conversation is on so many
topics so the ban is if you don't know
is the person who when he goes to
Berkeley requires requires to give a
speech we have a little bit less
security in the last two years
I get it from both sides in a way that's
completely surreal because they're so
for instance you were often disparaged
as a Nazi or a white supremacist but
even if you are not going to notice the
yarmulke you were actually the most
targeted victim of anti-semitism and
you're also often compared to your
former Breitbart colleague my lowly
innopolis right and that's that's an
unfortunate pairing is because the
reason why I'm wanted to talk to you is
because well I think you and I will
disagree about several maybe
foundational things I see you as someone
who is sincerely defending a position
based on a rational chain of
argumentation based on first principles
that we may or may not share but you're
not a performance artist and that's a
crucial distinction I think I'm not
going in somebody else to make a
headline that's why I've always a little
bit puzzling because there are
provocateurs whose job it is to go into
university say something deliberately
provocative just to get a rise out of
people
I've been puzzled frankly by the level
of opposition all sides is very weird
year last year was a weird year they'd
be all right calling me a writer so is
2016 we're still living a parallel
universe in which Marty McFly actually
did not stop it from using the sports
yearbook one lens through which I want
us to view that this conversation is
what worries you and I was actually the
first approximation
consciousness believe structure there
was enough shared complex for us to
function as a country I think that
that's gone away so I think this is the
parent of the crisis which I
increasingly think of because it's
called the donating revolution of N
squared revolution we're in some sort of
new regime which doesn't like any
revolution we've seen before it's much
less physically violent so far and what
are the ideas or sets of ideas that you
think are most culpable for bringing us
here well it's tough I think that what
really happened historically is that we
have this beautiful period of fairly
reliable predicated all of our
institutions on his expectation that
this was some sort of normal thing
depend upon future but it ran out and we
were left with all of our institutions
looking in some form or another like
Ponzi schemes and in order to keep
running an institution that expected
growth when a steady-state condition
let's say you need to change the
narrative to create some sort of as if
the growth story so you start stealing
from the future you start stealing from
that our slices grow so well there are
certainly areas that kept growing
communications and computation so there
was some real growth maybe fracking but
in general what we have is we have a
bunch of institutions that used to be
capable of honesty the problem is we've
had this growth across the spectrum for
most of our adult lives
that story which is a fiction right now
not one of these anti-capitalist I've
been hearing about all right you're the
managing director of teal capital so
that I'm so does that be well I mean see
you think economics is the longest lever
here that's influencing the Machine this
breakdown of our bid this failure of a
polite conversation to get us to
converge on a meaningful worldview what
you have markets take over from
something very creepy come online from
let me just acknowledge I'm actually a
bad podcast you're not with an expert
here you're a good sport really
important that we growth stops
proceeding at the levels of its expected
people can form families in real time
the fertility is threatened people can't
plan or for coupling in for a future I
think it gets right into the most
intimate details of our lives when when
the markets don't materialize in the way
that we need them so what is keeping you
up at night social collapse I don't
think it's easy to overstate geeks and
to which growth is stagnated I mean we
are to 4% of unemployment is not I mean
it's not 1935 this is not even
there's still you know significant
brother to me it seems like the social
fabric has been completely and
some of that is due to social media
uneffective we coordinate with each
other in different way but I think a lot
of it has to do with loss of common
values like even the ability to have a
common conversation in order to have a
conversation with one another we have to
take certain things for granted like
human reason like objective truth we
don't take these basic things every for
granted then television speaking the
same language is used either a lot of
those things that disappeared in favor
of radical subjectivism that maybe made
us feel good doesn't provide the common
framework for a conversation and
objective truth goes by the wayside
because we can't have a conversation you
see this particularly in our politics
where it seems like there's two bubbles
that have been created and free
Huffington Post you are in a completely
different world than if you read
breitbart right and my mom actually
first noticed this in 2012 Peter said I
was working part of lunch said well it
looks like Breitbart Romney's definitely
gonna wind up again all my friends at
work read Huffington Post and they said
Obama is definitely gonna win and I
don't know but believe I said well I
really don't know who to believe either
because no one knows the answer to that
question but you can see that it's
broken down an incredibly radical ways
now because even things where there
should be a common basis of that people
are disagreeing on incident take a
Senate race in Alabama right there's
pretty good reliable accounts that the
Republican candidate in that race is
likely guilty of some form of sexual
abuse underage girls and a huge
percentage of the Republican base in my
party my group a huge percentage of them
outright denied that's the case because
those people are out to get more and
more it's a conspiratorial attack on
more so that's one example from the
right there on the Left you'll have the
examples where you will say things that
are biologically true it can be
controversial example like there's a and
if you say that then people lose their
minds because you're some colic
insulting their subjectivity and when
you do that it's hard to have a
conversation because people will change
the terms they're using they'll change
the frame of reference they're using and
power within and then they'll toss the
reason out altogether to say you know
your specific bias as a person prevents
you from even having
simple conversation right your white
privilege or your background or your
ethnicity or all of this prevents us
from even discussing on a one-on-one
level I can recognize my background they
have but that is supposed to be a
conversation stopper Vendrell example I
was supposed to have a conversation yeah
that's why identity politics is so toxic
in my view because of EPs identity his
paramount communication is impossible
because you haven't shared my specific
experience with because you don't have
the same skin color you're not the same
gender there's no bridge between us
right then and in your and there's no
chain of reasoning from you to me that
should trump anything I currently think
because what I think is anchored to
identity we don't share another bore
atomized individuals that balancing off
one another is supposed to be able to
form a bond it's completely collapsed
right right and it is you think social
media is the main engine of that
collapses just we were headed there
anyway I mean obviously Fox News and
then maybe fragmentation of media
perceived social media so we had our
equity market social media Thursday
there's a economic forum is Harvard
actually talking about how the impact of
social media polarizations overstated
that you look the most polarized
populations in the country
older people gain steam as I say even
basic concepts like reasons are being
thrown out in favor of a philosophy of
feeling because maybe it does come down
to lack of success for people maybe
people do feel that they can succeed in
other ways and so the way that they feel
fulfilled when they fill whatever need
they have for fulfillment is by while
earning themselves fill in the outer
world and I will look inside me and I
will look at what makes me special
and therefore you can actually be able
to experience in order to empathize
across these dividing lines this
incredible failure of imagination if
there was no screenwriter who's able to
write both male and female characters I
think it has to do with pushing
interesting but very limited heuristics
so far beyond their debate of
applicability to techniques one of these
things using the Google angry to find
out where they came right it seems to me
that we're struggling and it's not your
size so all of us are struggling to find
a way to capture meaning and value in
the context of irrational
worldview and and I think that is a
challenge that just doesn't go away that
is a perpetual challenge and so far as
we understand the situation we're in we
need to find ways of talking about that
so as to converge with a basic life plan
with seven billion strangers and the one
difference between us is what we think
the value of religion is in that picture
so you said to get a little bit better
the context are what you are you're an
Orthodox Jew what does that actually
commit you to with respective beliefs
and what do you believe that I don't
believe that is selling in here they
said oh I'm an atheist so well let's see
well I believe that he cares what
happens to us as virtue of perspective
which doesn't really impact public
policy so much more than the reasons
that I think we can have a conversation
is that when it comes to public policy
discussions I try as little as possible
to refer to the local touch if you
almost never know if you mainly because
what would it appeal to Authority they
don't believe in do so in the area so I
think we can actually have a
conversation we're not talking about the
value of cash for keeping Sabbath which
I think has very little you know
relevant input for public policy or the
kind of social fabric building that
we're talking about doing stuff that I
think is important where we disagree is
man made in God's image created taking
the premise endowed us with the capacity
to choose
we sit right anymore sitting on our bike
well so ones where can be submerged
asleep unattended but so I mean so what
I'm interested in is in a worldview that
could be rebooted or rediscovered now I
mean just imagine we lost all of our we
had a all the libraries burned the
internet went down we lost all of our
texts how would someone rediscover this
thing now you I can we can make an easy
case that we could rediscover science
you know it might take some time but if
the literature of Judaism in your case
were lost
it seems to me tapeli obvious that
whatever is true about reality is still
there to be discovered and if there's
some part of reality that is ethical or
spiritual or divine or spooky it's there
it is there to be discovered by sentient
creatures such as ourselves so what
would how would you reboot religion
about the religion that's true because
you are by accident born a Jew right
right and there's you know there are a
billion people in India who weren't the
end I must imagine they have the wrong
version of this which is unnecessary
ground shift historically from certain
ways of thoughts and other ways of
thought like he happens in
judeo-christian thought change the way
of thinking but I think that they are
also things that you can discover
through contemplation for example so all
the things that I said about free will
and reason and the president's have been
highly mover that's more resilient than
it is judeo-christian right and that is
stuff that was essentially discovered
from philosophy not through revelation
so that wasn't stuff when I talked about
the necessity for reason that messes up
I think that is more relevant now I
think that you two need a religious
system in order to inform people for
difference around philosophizing all
right what are good and bad modes of
behavior both are thought the same so I
think that the notion of the glimpse
when is it important to believe that
those good and bad modes were approved
of or discouraged by an omniscient being
I mean can't we just chart a course
toward greater fulfillment in the world
it's true that an evolutionary
perspective on ourselves suggests that
we have not evolved to know real
perfectly I mean we're you know if you
believe that we are apes that have been
selected for anion and all of our
cognitive architecture is built by
virtue of its adaptive advantage in
evolutionary terms yes it's hard to
believe that we are perfectly designed
to do mathematics or anything else that
is that you do feel better we still
gather objective truth but simple buts
but that even that picture suggests a
wider context of minds more powerful
than our own that could have evolved or
our own future Minds know that we I
would argue we don't have any evidence
for what we do have evidence for is that
we're here we under we understand a lot
about the mechanism that is operating
now that got us here and that is causing
us to be the way we are we can see our
relationship to other life forms we know
that you we can look at chimps that
share 99% of our DNA and they obviously
share a lot of them evolved precursors
of our own social and cognitive
architecture but they have no idea what
we're up to right so they're cognitively
closed to most of what we're doing and
most of what we care about and by by
analogy we know that we could be
cognitively closed to what we might be
capable of in a thousand years now and
there our sense of what engagement with
the cosmos once you want to admit is
possible to not know what you're missing
factually ethically spiritually images
in any in any domain of inquiry it's
possible to come up against a horizon
line where the known meets the unknown
you sensitive religious would be the
first to say it's clearly possible not
to know what your mission and if you
killed the hundred smartest
mathematicians on earth right now you
would Derek their trouble you would
close the door
conversations maybe for 200 years maybe
not but so again by analogy it would be
just it would be too serious hubris to
think that the 7 billion of us who are
currently here collectively or anyone
individually have pushed the human
conversation to the limit what's a
rationally apprehended about the
universe so we know we know there's more
out there in every sense so you what
you're imagining is that every set is
very well know in every sense that I
mean this is wired from from the Atheist
perspective or from the perspective of
not being convinced of any religion this
is what's so limiting about this notion
of Revelation because what you have here
will you're entering a world view to a
book that we know we would just know by
the time of its composition and by its
actual contents yeah subsume raising
attila the larger world view that we're
gathering every visitor I think ask me a
little bit right because the bit of the
argument that I was making was based on
an Aristotelian philosophical view of an
unmoved mover and I'm certainly fit
certain properties that we have to have
as human beings in order to create a
civilization in Revelation which I
freely admit in this revelation were to
be destroyed smart I cannot recreate the
Torah remembering right well I better
have not been able to recreate it it's
just what is its importance apart from
being one among millions of books that
have inspired people to meet important
important you know Christian revelation
in our particular context it is the
creator of the entire chain of events or
it is least the progenitor along with
great book
largely of an entire chain of events and
thought that lead to these now is
there's a modern science that you're
relying on and with a bit of that's a
that's a set of historical contingencies
that are but there was no one element
here is that you could also say that
virtually everything that has been
accomplished in human history was
accomplished by people who didn't know a
damn thing about biology right there was
no one else in this job every bridge
that was built that's every beautiful
building that was built was built by
somebody who knew nothing about DNA
but that's not an argument that
ignorance of molecular biology is a good
thing or that should be it should be
maintained that our differences when I'm
arguing is no but I'm just well I would
I would say that any kind of religious
sectarianism is a species of ignorance
now that we shouldn't be I mean I'm
strong and it's again an assumption that
you're making based on premises that I
don't necessarily agree with on your
account the Hindus have to have it wrong
I mean if they're worshipping an
elephant head of God and what's the
significance if you're going to go to
Aristotle and you're going to go to
seven precepts that anyone could
discover so as to lead a well-ordered
life what is the significance of being
Jewish so this being Jewish even the
foundations what Aristotle believed that
he's trying to arrive through that he's
trying to arrive at logically have to be
perverted by a faith in a God who also
provides us some level of moral guidance
because even the priests of the first
hour are too broad to actually create a
civilization upon which we stand man
this is not a Greek civilization this a
Greek slash today of Christian
civilization it's the Athens in
Jerusalem and the typical phraseology
and if you just knock out the color of
Jerusalem then you're ignoring the
impact that Jerusalem historically
speaking well this is kind of reminded
me of the moment when I debated Rick
Warren once you know at Saddleback
justjust in his office was just the two
of us and Jon Meacham who was moderating
and he was he was telling me that
basically without God you know people
would just be raping and killing him and
then you require this as an anchor for
an ethical life and he even said of
himself a man I don't believe this one
when anyone says this but this is sort
of the bluff that never gets called he
said of himself that without he didn't
believe there was a hell he would be
raping and killing them
idea without anybody here they're fair
enough but what I do believe is that
scientific materialist world view cannot
construct a moral system because is has
nothing to do with thought science is
about isn't it has no capacity to say
anything about God other than
instructions that are based in a notion
of free will but you yourself reject I'm
a well I'm happy to get into them all
that you know time is short but I've
written two books on on those two but if
that were true how would you explain the
moral character of my life I'm assuming
I'm not raping and killing people within
a very life that you would recognize I
mean as I just said moments ago I don't
think that you have to be able to person
to lead a moral life I do think that
there has to be a system because I don't
think that you can they're using
terminology that is based on certain
assumptions about human nature that I'm
not sure that you are recognizing that
you retired right let's take the very
basis very base they're basically balls
of meat wandering through the universe
with a bit of self-awareness attached
we're sort of Spinoza's stones they've
been thrown and we know that we've been
thrown we don't have control over our
own behavior we have control over what
we do we know many people who would take
an evolutionary picture of ourselves
also imagine we have free will and the
rotors did that perspective with the
free will peace and play they're back to
actually think there are moral insights
we can have when we see through the
illusion of free will which we we really
can't easily have without doing that and
then I want to bring you in here
it's a good distinction I think a lot of
us has to do with pre-existing
architecture that predisposes us even
though our rational minds may know
better or something functions very much
religious context well steak is a nod
for a second because I mean here's one
way those two things collapse for me yes
understanding how the universe is all
together you know all the possibilities
of experience all the ways Minds emerge
all of the kinds of good lives and bad
lives and all of the mechanisms that
would determine one path over another a
complete understanding of the mind and
the cosmos that's all as all of the is
all the is there that is there to be
understood if understanding that
couldn't give you a complete picture of
what you ought to do where would you go
to get that picture if you sum all the
facts how does that not give you a way
to chart your course in this universe
what what else is there to inform your
life well
we can bring to our fingers like
Quicksilver that are exactly the
situation with these things oddest
superstitious utility is the
one-dimensional object became the
utility of this utility I can be happy
that can mean interested if you just
notice your mom you'll notice there all
sorts of things which I that's a great
example her there
reverse again but but that move to the
deeper level is more fax it's more
context we already objected what I think
is an objective claim a fact but I think
has moral that you won't agree with then
that I think has moral consequence that
we should grapple with so the editors
connects to a very real-world issue like
wealth inequality as a wealth inequality
is a problem if you think it's problem
or it's inevitable if you think it's
inevitable but it's I think everyone
would agree that some level of wealth
inequality would be intolerable and that
we would want to correct for it but
wealth inequalities just one kind of
inequality there's every other kind of
inequality and there's this fact that
none of us is supposed to the free will
is you so it's so what we we imagine is
that people they have some certain
inheritance they they have their genes
they have their environments they didn't
pick the fact that you weren't born
yesterday and in Syria you were born in
stable society when you were born we
don't know
truly owned all of our advantages we
didn't make ourselves but most people
feel that there's something like a ghost
in the machine that has free will that
can make the best or even a bad
situation now I think you probably mean
some situations are so bad that the deck
can be so stacked against you that you
know it's just life is unfair I think I
mean here are claims about you that I
that that I think are true and have a
kind of go there should be morally
salient you didn't make yourself you
didn't determine anything about yourself
that you would use as an exercise of
your own free will so you're you're very
intelligent you're very literate you're
very interested in things that get you
ahead in all the ways you've gotten
yourself ahead you didn't create that
about yourself
right and obviously there's there's a
genetic component to that there's an
environmental component to that there's
a maybe there's just you know cosmic ray
bombardment that can help or hurt who
knows what what influences are there but
none of that is something that you have
authored and that's true of everyone in
the room you have exactly the
disposition you have the efforts you
have if you wake up tomorrow morning
with twice the capacity for effort and
grit that you had yesterday you won't
know where that came from if it cut if
it comes from a book you read you can't
determine the fact that the book had
precisely the influence it had and not a
little bit less or a little bit more you
are part of a system of influences and
so there's a picture in my view that
just makes a mockery of the notion of
free will right and goes down to the
smallest possible case of you know my
getting to the end of the sentence right
let's just you know like if I have a
stroke now well then you know sorry I
can't do it but I didn't I didn't choose
that either so now that I think I think
taking that on board does not rob us of
morality I think because because we
still have a preference between an
excruciating plunge into civil war and
and needless misery and build in a
viable global civilization where the
maximum number of people thrive so but
you see a lot of active verbs for
personally supportive environments and
genetics
what of it no but it's all it's all
happening like if I were we can build
robots that act right and we are I'm
moving my hands now but I honestly don't
know the point that I'm making is when
you say we can we can to serve we can
build we can create we can you know we
can decide but it's exactly like you
speaking now you are you don't know how
you follow the rules of English the
moral relevance of this and Erica to
know if you agree with us it seems to me
that once you admit you you either won
the lottery or you didn't on some level
that conveys a kind of ethical
commitment or an ethical obligation that
you wouldn't otherwise have you can't be
the person who then says everyone just
basically you're on your own you either
make it based on your effort or not I
mean this goes to questions appeal
should we have universal health care
it's not just equate it's not just for
literally decades there there were very
wealthy and very sophisticated countries
that took the premises that you are
building upon and built in the most
repressive regimes in history they had
other things going on they had bad ideas
of economic and they had personality
cults that the point I'm making is that
you are you're making a definitive
statement about value judgment with
reference to natural owning the the
truth of biology do not have moralities
no they certainly would if we built them
to have conscious states that would
allow for suffering and well-being I
mean that'd that's coming we're gonna
have to ask that question I thought it
was crying
chemistry building the National
Assessments election rally riding on top
of this and there's some sort of weird
category there between the layers of
this cake so it may be eternity that you
have effective velocity and determinism
and everything is product of initial
conditions and that takes place at the
lowest level but there's no more
equality of exciting so you know you
don't put care that observable which is
like you know I've had pork and beef
right now you know with some behavior
which you know fire so that's that
morality thing has to do with this very
high up layer which is some sort of
social organization which is not
fundamental what I'm guaranteeing is
talking about free will down here I'm
talking about the reality up here every
layer of the cake has what has its own
language game associated with it and
yeah you can make all those observable
those observables are paired with what
we might call effective theories and so
these effective theories are not to be
mixed up the target let me get into one
of these from three little conversations
I don't know whether you're talking
about three and we have as if who-who
was forced to buy a ticket to the
night's event but they answer that
question really says like I know like
did did you did you actually observation
and get back to some higher level three
but but it's as if free will only
because you actually are not aware of
the proximate cause of your action
over the Exploratorium it may have a
very clear path let's determine through
Newtonian mechanics put about smart
enough to figure it out so effectively
I'm super surprised is it like an idiot
rolling in Tokyo ha
[Laughter]
well but you would still you're not
disparaging the idea of a unity of
knowledge right yeah each layer of the
cake you can make a smooth transition
between layers that doesn't save you
that you serve your understanding of
each layer the ideas that maybe that the
quantum field theory determines our
behavior
no but there's nothing about doing
dishes that it violates quantum field
theory one one person I mean so it's not
that you have to live in a different
world view in order to talk about the
human relations layer that the moral
layer the freewill layer or not I think
useful to try to think about human
psychology from the point of view of
course of course so there are some ways
in which these different layers to talk
to each other but there's no reason
there is some sort of determination what
I'm interested in is kind of a first
principle methodology of moving forward
into the unknown right cycle is what I
would object to in religion and then
this notion of Revelation is that there
was some prior century where we were
given the best ideas we're ever going to
have on a specific topic and we must
cling to those ideas until the end of
time this is the analogy that or the
rubric that that I find most convincing
is like oh there's there's only ever
been people talking about reality here
right and you can actually therefore you
can either locate yourself in a current
modern open-ended conversation or you
can anchor yourself to an ancient one
and never give yourself the freedom to
rethink it so and you could have done it
with Homer you could have done it with
Aristotle you could have done it with
Shakespeare and the Hindus have done it
with the Ramayana and the Mahabharata
and you're losing no sleep over whether
or not you should do likewise right and
so I but my sense is that we need to
every question of societal importance
requires that we now outgrow the
accidents of merely contingent history
outgrow the fact that people used to be
live in the image geographical isolation
from one another and linguistic
isolation from one another for centuries
and outgrow therefore our religious
provincialism and just get to a common
humanity that's using the best tools
available is all the harder problems
okay but this is a philosophical
confusion that that you're me try to
just address it reason does not require
freewill reason requires a didn't see me
having a mind that can follow an
argument and to care about whether or
not you're following it but me
responding to your argument it's not a
matter of choice
so what everybody's been saying is
reason is never a matter of choice if I
convince is really superior to the
amygdala response response
well because wanted it's scalable wanted
it's it's if I give you sufficiently
good reasons for anything right
you will helplessly believe what I
believe it will be a matter of choice
you never choose will wider why are you
giving me the ring if I prove to you but
I use no body active verbs for capacity
I'm doing using my language they don't
think using the bricks I'm giving you no
no the stick with reason they're the one
brick reason is a mode of influence
whereby if you if you see the syllogism
actually runs through right or they just
speak of reason even more broadly if I
give you a set of facts that persuade
you of something that before this moment
you were unaware of or thought was
untrue you will helplessly take that on
board if you're reasoning right so if if
I show you that just those two makes
four and you can't see it any other way
even though you wish it made five you
will help us we believe that two plus
two makes four even choose it you never
choose it well it's nice is is the
prototypical here since the current
situation you did a lot of people choose
not to believe we have but that's a
failure of rationality I agree that
rationality is the quintessential moment
where free will is not in evidence if I
show you is he no no no but that's
changing the subject let's let's just
take this one breaker subject your no
but you're saying you can't have reason
without free will or the reason people
don't have reason without making an
assumption about the about the function
of the human mind that is not evidenced
by evolutionary biology or science the
reason reason maps are the both Eric
Erica helped me here but
in my view reason maps onto reality
there's a fit between it's not a it's
not a perfect fit and the hence our
predicament but reasons but there is a
certain gurantees or morally appropriate
than the pirate of other nervous sorry
well I would be happy to get that but
let me just stick with reason for a
second reasons reason maps onto reality
that's why it is reason like so it again
selected just arithmetic if I take two
objects you know I have two oranges here
and I've I've them and I add two more
right you're just in order to have some
any rational expectation of what's now
behind the chair you're doing arithmetic
right that's best just reasoning about
objects it's not the best it's the fact
that that is so reliably
I'm not arguing with giving you don't
agree reason exist I'm hardly they
killed at your home mode of creating our
societal morality is based upon this
sort of this reason and you're making
the moral argument that reason is
superior to any other method of the
listening or response the way that you
are talking about reason is that reason
is basically a key you stick it in the
lock of my thinking and suddenly the
door opens so why is that it's why I'm
asking you
there are many ways to open that door
including using a battering ram which
has been the preferred method most
governments over history you need to
make an argument to me why is more moral
are you getting to the odd of reason
without any appeal to immorality that
exists beyond you especially into
complex moral questions that are not too
close to equals or and then questions
some sort of weird reverent state and
the two of us agreed us for each other
over and we can better outcomes and can
be that gives me compare outcome than if
I just applied reason in a particular
way or maybe which we need to apply or
if I ask you the question putting the
square root of negative 1 and you say
whoa there's no square root of negative
garden until some years later it becomes
like with the complex numbers right but
that's irrational to run from a bear
this is when you're right this is like a
beautiful thing and I think you're very
attached to it I like the light
but if you know if you know but we
acknowledge that that is a failure of
rationality that should matter to them
and it and thing is it doesn't it no but
it does matter to them when they notice
it in others it can matter to them when
you can show it to them in themselves
right I mean are you just closing the
door to a hope that bit conversation can
ever get us to converge with get into
arguments in which rules
this research at endgame chess moves
rent right had pretty soon be set to two
rooks in the back rank in the inner King
has nowhere to go and so he says you
know okay I think you sort of got me but
I bet if I went home I can figure out
what it is that I agree to that proved
to me that if eight-cell embryo is
actually a human life it has to be
protected that's right and so right for
though but we all have these intuitions
with a fighting a promotion with an
operating and complex Mexican standoff
people will show up when you decide to
visit San Francisco you can do more with
reason the might be crazy
we might be bounding reason it's just a
set of operations a little differently
again back to the bear right I mean the
antithesis to reason is not emotion the
split between reason and emotion is has
always been false and what you feel when
you're pretty sure that what I'm saying
is is an emotion right that the
feeling of doubt but the only enough no
no no you got it wrong that sense and
you want to jump in before I embarrass
myself further
right that's a feeling that minutes we
understand the neurology of that and
people who can't feel the consequence
emotionally of their own incoherence
don't you they're just happy to
confabulate right they're just they have
no truth testing and one of them is now
running the country but it's it matters
again to come back to your point it
matters because it's the only thing the
scales it's the only thing that you can
put over the transom to a total stranger
who is sane and who cares to have
is math of the world actually fit the
world to first approximation is the only
limits it's like the how do you how did
we all get to this theater tonight you
know you make a left you make a right
you make a left you go a bit like the
directions work for everybody like we're
sitting under some super dangerous
there's somebody with the engineering
school use a lot of easier okay but you
don't need an unmoved mover to sit under
this you just need to know their job
techniques that were used in my
great-grandfather's right but it but
again the primacy of reason and the
promise of it is that it's the only
thing that stands a chance here of being
universal in even a way that's beyond
humanity right a mobile above this
whatever we're calling reason ultimately
is going to be inscribed in the future
machines chronic repetitive religion
each of our religions are some sort of
particular instantiation and I think
that what's top once you get to the
point where you actually you know swim
back up and decide annoy me why I
believe that okay that's something that
needs to go their normal thing begins to
degrade that's why all three of us in my
opinion are living in some kind of
tension between it's hard to talk about
that other thing is lend itself to the
language of reason but I don't want to
get this is where I still get confused I
don't see the departure from reason for
me is where you're pretending to know
something you don't know right your
protect your pretending to think
something is great evidence when it's
it's obviously not great evidence and
you recognize it to not be great
evidence when someone else does it by
another name so presumably you're not
losing sleep over whether to convert to
Islam you see that there 1.7 billion
Muslims playing a very similar language
game with a very similar book but you
really don't care about that language
game and you don't care about that book
and you can see that their fixation on
this revealed tradition is probably not
with the universe right and so on any
tradition is just not accept in any of
these reason you can derive these value
based judgments when or on the nature of
the universe and that has not been human
history and is not history we won't draw
these lessons from this streem history
or generations of confused people just
like ourselves one thing I think
about is that we have a missive this
actually I think is a point of confusion
that was relevant here it's not that
everything is based on reason I mean you
can adjust it by everything right you
can just begin to see what works right
like this we went to well I may I
wouldn't I I don't answer to that name
happily because I think there's a lot of
confusion built into the way we teach
not a matter of assumptions a matter of
just realizing that we live in a space
of possible experience and experience
can get very very bad or get very very
good and we have no idea how bad it can
get and we have some sense of how bad it
can get we don't want to go there but it
can presumably can get much worse in
different minds of the sort that we
don't it's not subjectivism it's just in
fact it's honoring the fact that what
we're calling subjective experience is
part of the cosmos this universe has an
interior dimension that you know I would
call consciousness so if there are
systems that it is like something to be
right the lights are turned on and we
you know I'd be the first to admit that
we don't understand how that happens
scientifically yeah we don't understand
the relationship between consciousness
in the brain and any way that I can
defend at the moment but presumably the
brain is involved and whenever we have a
good reason to believe that that's the
case but we have this what I consider a
navigation problem we as conscious
systems can plunge into excruciating
misery or we can based on all the tools
that we can get our hands around and
reason is one of them begin to
collaborate in a way that allows for
more and more beauty and creativity and
insight and flourishing and we know we
like that right and we and we don't have
to justify suffice to pleasure a matrix
is everything every conceivable facet of
what you would recognize as your
well-being and facets yet to be
discovered and again we were having a
talk backstage about psychedelics so
the virtues one of the virtues of
psychedelics is that if nothing else it
will prove to you that it is possible to
have a very different experience than
the one you're attending to have I'll
take it and that and certainly some of
the experiences that people have on
psychedelics seem to cash out the kinds
of claims that mystics and and and very
religious people have made through the
ages I mean it's very easy to see the
psychedelic experience through a kind of
architect eclis religious lens but you
know I would argue we need not there's
other ways to react to a burning bush
beyond becoming an Orthodox Jew or a
fundamentalist Christian and I think we
need a 21st century response to the fun
debate
it's all very fifty-nine statements
about biblical references is
metaphorical ridiculous right there's no
actually not if you take a stab you it
can be quite literal I mean I'm gonna
get I'm at me and it's like look about
this but it's like there is an
experience you can have and again it's
not you don't need psychedelics to have
it but there's an experience you can
have what if you pay sufficient
attention you can have an encounter with
nature data I mean the burning bush is a
little more than a metaphor we're sort
of embarrassed to say truth meaning
fitness and grace and so very often I
just I don't find that very fulfilling
and this concept of meaning in certain
things feeling meaningful very hard for
me to say what you're doing is
successful
lynnie does he get to keep playing so if
somebody puts a gun to my head and ask
me questions I try to do what it says
they want to hear that not what answers
a tree my bracelet was weird quality
where I had to take issue had been when
he talks about gender pronouns I don't
match the phenotype truth it's a
violation of grace it is a great acetic
we really before so we take see some
place where I have to retract it you
know that's a small difference so you
know fundamentally again this is a place
where either I don't take your point or
or I disagree but what I think he wanted
for those things to cohere in a way that
doesn't violate truth right so we you
don't have to lie yourself to get the
grace and the fitness and not know but
not well is that the only way to get the
meaning and the grace that you want and
I would say that's not the case maybe
it's a medium can become uncoupled from
truth in a way that you would
acknowledge as synonymous with madness
right if I mean in in things that no one
else can recognize it meaningful and you
talk too much about it you're the person
that who gives look at the license
plates and they say but it's important
to notice
it's important to do such okay that is a
command miss experience in order to
guard against madness so I'm thinking
you have to I am open for example to
suspending my existence I'm treated for
periods of time I need the example of
the square root of negative quadrant who
ever figured out the complex numbers
probably started saying there's my
solution there's no solution can quite
hit something I don't even know what it
is groping around in the dark and the
hand waving from very start lying about
it and then and then you can find me
right to you usually take an advance on
the truth when you go into these other
spaces and then hopefully if you're
lucky you get to higher ground and you
can start talking about truth all over
again
yeah but that spot that's a kind of a
happy spiral which is not the same thing
as delusion or so yours not sustained
delusion the basically you want to say
you want to perturb yours your
consciousness in ways so as to depart
from rigor so that you can get back to
rigor a bit better
I did have an acid trip where I was
planning to confess my psychedelic
misadventure streams apropos and this
story will prevent them from ever trying
acid this is a perfect example of
meaning and and everything else all the
good stuff becoming uncoupled from it so
appropriate object I was on acid be able
to say and staring at a photograph also
started a human face that I was taken to
be just the most radiant exemplar of
sainthood I had ever seen inappropriate
and I'm staring at this thing and happy
and you know the the beatific vision in
the eyes of another and if anyone's ever
taken acid and looked at a photograph
you know the person you know what I mean
but I was so staring in awe for an
eternity and then when I came down to
the point where I could recognize who I
was staring at it was a cover
of TV Guide with dick Van Dyke's you
know puddle of coke I'm on the sidewalk
breaking you never let go bye-bye birdie
but but the issue is I think we wanted
me that the struggle is to get the most
meaningful moments personally and the
most useful ways of thinking personally
and collectively to a line in such a way
that we can the only way to play a
language game successfully with other
people is to not have it be the cover of
TV Guide and Dick Van Dyke and have it
be something that is a appropriate
object of everyone else's attention so
that you can you can communicate your
experience of meaning and that's the
challenge of Romania insane and
collaborating with others what is one
one sane person
listen I think I think we need the
wisdom and sanity of the crowd at this
moment so we are going to not just
immediately open it up to questions from
you all we've raised a few topics here
left and right until we run out of time
we have about 40 minutes I would say and
so the people who are standing the back
of the line to feel a sense of
hopelessness so but the people the front
of the line we will definitely get to
you so I will get as far as we can get
but as you can see we're long winded so
can we turn the lights up a little bit
more so we can
then you don't get to make demands on
because that is and so I don't think
that religious rights for example a
person who writer for President Obama
and now I'm walking this ready for me in
this cattle water is ready absolutely
right to do that I think shop owners
regardless mother using their religious
I think I'm a full believer I'm a
libertarian on this I think that you
have the complete right to be as much of
an as you want to be so long as
you're not infringing on the rights of
others and you do not have a right to
buy a cake for me
so I'm completely libertarian on this I
also think that you'll go out of
business because the person will go
cross the street sometimes bakery and
put them out of business if you can find
a if you can find a cake shop that is
owned by a person in the United States
good luck to you it just seems like an
argument wouldn't have held up in the
60s in the south and open to people so
they're bad people of course is the
government to tell people who they can
count on kannur - I don't think so I
think the solution is for the markets
take care of us and for social pressure
to take care of the problem so thank you
we actually agree with what then said
there except I would I would acknowledge
that there are periods in human history
where everyone would benefit from some
kind of enlightened pressure coming from
the top right so that you could have
leaders and governments who are wiser
certainly earlier than most of the
people in the society and it would be a
good thing to just legislate the most
important truths they're more immoral
truths so if you think equality is super
important and does good things you need
political equality but you have you know
what we're talking about it you know
India with a caste system say it would
be good to just remove the caste system
even though most people might still want
to go back 150 years but there are
moments and I think me know now is a
moment where you I think we pay an
unacceptable prize for legislating some
of these things and so he's forcing
people to bake a cake it seems
ridiculous to me even morally and
politically now but if you're going to
talk about that you the civil rights
movement and what was appropriate in
1964 I think you could give some kind of
local horrible case where they're just
in there
racists Boris you know as far as anyone
can comfortably walk or drive so that
you have to have the government to
legislate some kind of equality because
otherwise nothing is going to change
quickly enough to matter and I don't
know where that line is but the
principle is equality is so important
that we should enshrine it and enforce
it in any way we can and but I would I
would agree with you that most of that
now is a matter of talking to one
another and using the social pressure
but then it sounds like you're saying no
we should we should over man that was a
moment where we've them the market was
failing or I would argue the market was
failing the larger question of what
should what should be privatized and
what should be done by governments
everything that is best done privately
should be done privately but we should
recognize that there's some things that
are not best on privately in governments
to do those things change depending on
history
Yeah right over here one of the reasons
why some of the arguments for the
existence of God don't resonate with me
are because they rely on seemingly
unfalsifiable claims do you do you also
do believe that determinism is
falsifiable first of all and then if if
if you don't is there a distinction
between the unfalsifiable 'ti of
determinism and the falsifiability of
the existence of God well determinate
amad
I don't really need determinism for if
you're speaking specifically about my
argument against freewill it's it's
determinism plus whatever randomness you
want to throw in there so it's my
problem with freewill is that there is
no account of how causes can happen and
lead to events that lead to further
events there's just no account whether
it's determined or random or combined
that makes sense of what I think most
people mean by free will if it doesn't
make sense to you in five minutes it may
take an hour to talk about if I wrote a
short book on it and I've talked about
in a bunch on my podcast
whether you are a robot made of meat
right that that certainly isn't a good
basis for free will if I told you in the
middle of your processor we added a
random number generator that threw in
quantum randomness or or you know we
just keep rolling dice that doesn't add
this thing that that people think is
there it's unfalsifiable in some sense
busy it's not it's not an empirical data
it's actually just an incoherent idea
it's like saying there's a round square
that's the best responsible square it's
not what I mean by square there's just a
logical contradiction there thank you
for coming
Bennett's and with them up revealing
your
thing about truth going back about it
and seem like n was a Jewish the truth
is this foundational precept that we can
then derive like make other truth claims
on and I'm getting the black pudding
from Sam is that great traditions
religions have these books have
incredible scaffold for moral framework
of cultural framework and that the
missionaries to me is like the shoe
evidence of that that you can take
people and give them this book and then
just send them off and they can drop
into random cultures and just we
architected whole cities Los Angeles was
missionary so that was thousands of
hundreds of years ago and we can cuenta
those books and even today they're
providing guidance for so many people
what is the modern equivalent of that
what is the great text that the Atheist
tradition would want them from which we
can we can have a wellspring of moral
constructs like Jordan Peter see that's
an incredibly child that the biblical
series of taking the Bible and then
spinning off all of these these
understand bar typical truths from which
we can kind of derive ways to live I
don't know what the you know the Twitter
Instagram Kim Kardashian where are we
getting that from in the contemporary
culture well so the answer is the
totality of human knowledge and human
conversation that is useful at any
moment I'm not saying that you can't
read the Bible whatever you can find in
the Bible that's useful and beautiful
and true well I know that no argument
against using it it's just that there's
so much in there that is patently insane
and needlessly savage and absolutely
divisive if you take it seriously
certain sections of the missus but there
are other sections that are beautiful
and so again there's there's no you know
if you're going to say you read
Ecclesiastes this morning and it just
set the tone for your day and you just
you got no argument for me but but if
you're telling race and you in read the
Bible you you become one with a lot of
great roots and understandings about you
would come away you would come away with
almost no appreciation for how rich and
beautiful the human experience is even
now I mean like like there's not there's
about a single paragraph in the Bible
that could not have been written by
someone who lived fifteen hundred years
ago or if someone said I have no moral
foundation point me too to a book to get
started as a minister I've said it so
you know you can wander blindfolded into
a Barnes and Noble if the Barnes and
Nobles still exists and and find
something better than many of the
so-called moral books of the Bible and
agree disagree about this but I think
the precept that if your wife is found
not to be a virgin on your wedding night
you should take her to her father's
doorstep and stone her to death
right that's just a bad idea we don't we
don't have to venerate that we should be
able to cut that out of the human
conversation and because we have this
notion of Revelation we can and this is
much less of a problem with someone like
Ben and obviously it is an excruciating
problem when you're talking about the
Muslim world and what is being done with
the Quran and the Quran and hadith
taking together is like the worst
operating system that exists right and
it's running on the brains of almost two
billion people to one or another degree
and that's it that is a civilizational
challenge and in a veneration of this
notion of revelation is what it's
anchored to right we have to get out of
the revelation business and get into the
conversation begin to become what would
make you think we need a book I mean
this isn't a book this is just we're
writing a book
[Music]
you happy genetics in 1200 BC but it's
also true to say that it was possible
the moral system by which you suggested
course the publish may remove these
built on the moral system developed over
two cultures but but but it does exist
the existed BC it was possible in 500 BC
to enunciate a more ethical framework
than that the Buddha didn't say stone or
on a father's doorstep the Buddha was no
great promulgator of women's rights but
he wasn't that bad it's not it's not
really food as many values were pretty
much true but you know it though if
you're talking about where I came to my
most considered view of ethics it's by
having a much larger conversation with
all of the time rising Western
civilization predicated on
judeo-christian notions of good and bad
you can say that but again we're back to
bridge building the basic argument or
having to think you think all history is
contingent and I don't think all history
is continuing I think as you know that
the necessity the problem with religion
for me in many cases that it an apology
some people are still standing there but
any this is worth instead the better
angels of our nature are often better
than the doctrines that seem to inform
so much of human morality and the wheat
we you people don't come into this world
eager to stone other people to death for
thought crimes or for working on the
Sabbath or for not having a hymen just
this is what happens do you want to do
you think I'm not saying I mean we are
we are able so when a perfect most in
most cultures may people do come into
the world of each other for variety
reasons I mean that's absolutely true
you know the doctrines to be violent but
when you add when you have doctrines
that are clearly built on xenophobia and
superstition and an attitude toward
evidence that is unscientific should
just
promulgate them generation after
generation with no way of course
correcting because it is a nassima to
edit these traditions and to have the
best you can do is to sort of have some
further argument which
we don't have to honor this all the time
that it just seems like it slows down
moment where the rabbi goes along to a
and the rabbi says to them I have this
doctrine and I promise you it's right in
this end people of the room say it's
it's wrong we don't believe you he says
I'll prove to you that it's right it's
right then let the walls of the room
collapse in the walls unrelated people
say you know what that's not in favor of
your opinion that doesn't mean that it's
true because we were given the ability
to basically rule on the law and then
there's voice from heaven there's a
voice from heaven that comes in and says
these however beautiful
self-extinguishing if you have a
tradition without grace but it's the
metric that is talking about and
sometimes what happens is that you end
up be nature into these things so that
you get
beautiful itself terminating the other
issue it has to do with the fact that in
all of these issues the texts don't do
anything it's the machines interpret the
text even if you have a tradition like
prohibition against innovation in Islam
good luck
where you know how to innovate the text
isn't our construction control you're
not allowed whistles an extra structure
but you know binding repressor so that
the code doesn't run around to use a
genetic you have a situation in which
every religion asks to continue to adapt
and so whether about their prohibition
against innovation they are all
innovating and they're all trying to run
and some code more than a minute some
gets promoted some gets were present no
matter what they tell you you're allowed
to do it if it doesn't work out the
thing stuff terminates but when you're
looking at something which is an
absolutely enormous percentage of
humanity you have to ask yourself are
you upset with that thing because it
mileage grace or because it violates
fitness because of violence truth these
are all different things and I think
that it's just important to recognize
that the book Barnes & Noble they two
separate books Utley what you have to
communicate with your partner the
relationship and the other one that says
relationships are not about
communication that's where everything
goes wrong you start to realize that
there is this problem that we don't have
a great atheist text that tells us what
to do you want to go into a particular
religion you get this idea like in
Judaism of a father one single unified
voice that that works for you great
however you can also shop around and
deal was the dialectics in the
contradiction so I think you know in
some sense there's no way we've got a
struggle with it you have to think about
your novel and whole bunch of different
levels
oh good evening and thank you for
conversation I wanted to ask the
question and you touched on briefly in
the beginning which is about echo
chambers and the role of social media
Sam you had seen him to fetch a and have
some seen more recently cast especially
offered compelling evidence about you
know people's views getting more extreme
as they hang on
and I happen to agree with that but in
the valley there's a couple of different
views that oh the introduction social
media is just like the printing press or
and or you know if you blame all of this
on social media that means you're
discounting the fact that people have
agency basically they're saying that
your agency should overcome the
algorithm so that well I just think
what's insidious here is that again we
can be influenced we know this about
ourselves we can be influenced in ways
that we don't recognize in fact we are
all the time and the idea that a very
small number of people for purely
mercenary reasons can game our wetware
and convince us to spend our attention
in ways that in hindsight we think is
terrible misuse of our time and in waves
that produce conflict between people
that wouldn't otherwise occur I mean the
analogy to road rage is it seems more
and more apt just like a road rage is a
very strange phenomenon you get in the
car and you become this other person
right and I guess just a pane of glass
separating you from another hominid gets
you to act in ways that are just starkly
insane though the people who like get to
the point of pulling over to have a
fistfight with a stranger
in the car and they get out of the car
and then they realize oh my god this is
not the situation I thought I was in
sofa media is kind of kindling the road
rage part of the brain and we are
broadcasting these peroxisomes to
thousands and millions of people and
it's affecting everything and this is
all being gamed on the on the other side
by people who just want us to spend more
time on the platform and that we need to
understand what's happening and what
we're doing towards it we're all part of
the bad psychological experiment that no
one signed up for
there's no consent and we're consenting
by just by virtue of doing what we want
but if you've got you know a team of
brilliant engineers and marketers
turning the dials of what you want or
can be made to want every moment and
they have billions of dollars and then
now they have AI algorithms doing it
better and they're just trying to get 5%
more of your time
and and if it potentially changes
politics and changes governments and me
like oh this is again we're just we're
just talking about how influence happens
and we need to understand more and more
about where we want to go and should
want to go and how to get there and if
that HAP hazard quality of this that I
think disturbs so many people and the
option and seem things that are
obviously ugly and maladaptive that we
can't they extract ourselves from them
but would love to say one thing clearly
about this reaches them somebody
referred to the group of people which is
word yes I mean if somebody mentioned is
toward the Peters look what the hell is
word computers did two years ago nobody
knew it was and even though we disagree
with each other course since every
disastrous first podcast we've done but
the point is is that there is this group
with people that have gotten with
privileges to write two imaginary
newspapers that never existed
Twitter following them over 10,000
people the thing that used to control
incoherence was this thing I call indeed
an institutional narrative and you
couldn't write to it unless you lived in
one elite institution to Harvard or the
New York to the corner who reports with
New York Times just one more voice not
necessarily more interesting in general
these people do not want to talk to us
we have a much easier time talking
amongst ourselves might be very
Christian to differences because there
is this different substrate conversation
that's available to you so you know what
I would really consume that the bright
spot of this for me is meeting about
twenty five people or some kind either
becoming troglodytes in this direction
you know nor do
right they're not deplorable than enough
in architecture and so if you can find
this group of people this is the really
interesting thing to watch because I
think visit selectable dark web is what
we're supposed to reboot we have about
15 minutes left here so hi my name is
Bob trans well I wanted to say about
sexism in feminism I want to give you in
trouble but I'm trying to do are you
sort of do better than me and you know
standard disclaimers on the white dude
asking the three white dudes but I'm
into safe solutions right now we're in a
moment of outrage which i think is well
justified but what should we do as
humans I'm planning to tackle this on my
podcast
with a woman or actually did a series of
women so I talked about you know for
better for worse I mean it is something
that I can say my my default said I'm
very secure in my default setting here
because I do see this just by bias
frankly from the perspective of a woman
I mean when I when we talk about in
sexual harassment and you know elevator
gate or any of these moments where you
know a woman says she was made to feel
uncomfortable by a man you know I was
raised by a single mom you know I've got
two daughters I view all my self defense
thinking about violence privileges and
the fact that women are walking around
in this world out waived by men
virtually all the time you know my
default setting is to trust the woman's
account in all of these things and I
feel like men have a moral obligation
not to be priests and I see this this
you know I think in this case through
just through here good luck from the
perspective of a you know a little boy
who was raised by
other without a father in the house so I
get it and yet I also get I'm being a
guy I'm capable of not getting it right
so I want to put myself in conversation
with with it with a few smart women
journalists who can walk me through this
and I'll just table it for that podcast
it's cut off by two people in Vancouver
at the Q&A so welcome thanks really
happy that Sam and Ben are having a
conversation can you hear me
yep okay I tore out all my hair
listening to you say there's not enough
nuance on the conservative side of the
media spectrum in the car be up on your
podcast right after I've listened to
famines podcast we're just kidding
nuanced and there's a president my
question is actually for Eric I saw your
brother actually a couple days after I
saw Sam with Jordan Peterson in
Vancouver and I asked him a question
about the hygiene theory basically I've
spoken to you about it like these
experiences that Ben and Jordan Peterson
have had where people essentially freak
out when they hear opposing opposing
views and hygiene theory says that the
profile of or hypothesis sorry the
profile of people with the fewest number
of allergies are people are like kids
who have at least one other siblings
they're around animals they play outside
so they're exposed to all sorts of germs
and they develop both an immune system
whereas the people who use hand
sanitizer everywhere they tend to be the
opposite and have problems and so I was
I asked your brother if do you think
that the ideological
sort of the echo-chamber that that some
colleges and universities have become is
sort of like a journalist sanitized
environment is raising people to have
social allergic reaction outside with
your brother so I was
Rossi's worried that what we've done is
created people well briefly I just think
it's I think both sides of this argument
are necessarily crazy again we're
talking about the religious
balkanization of our world and we have
to get out of this problem as quickly as
possible it might be but I've you would
like to almost any decision he's likely
to make it's almost certainly based on a
very very little understanding of what's
actually going on in the world and
almost certainly impulsive and guided by
his own political needs at the moment or
pandering to some future voter he's
imagining that he needs I just I think
it's again we have the wrong persons in
charge and if he does something right
it's going to be by accident
that's your scarab so do you think it's
I think it's I think it's probably
needlessly inflammatory at this moment
it could possibly do something good they
could just sort of force the issue in a
way that could be productive I actually
don't know it's not the first thing I
would do as president but again I don't
have a strong intuition about what its
effects will be I think reality on the
ground and the preconditions for any
successful negotiation are going to be
recognized the reality on the ground
which this is the capital of Israel is
not giving up Jerusalem and the contrary
is operating
beyond that idea that Israel would give
up control over the holy sites in
Jerusalem which regardless whether you
believe that the holy or not certainly
are holy to billions of people around
the planet of various religions when
they have been under Muslim control in
the past when we for example 1948 1967
those sites are not open to Jews they
are open to Muslims now when Jews are in
control of them so I think that the
president made a a proper moral and
political decision I also think that a
lot of misses overblown meaning that
right now just geopolitically not a lot
of people actually care about this
outside of believer not Europe and the
United States meaning that the Saudis
are sort of pretending to care about
this these were the answer sort of tying
together but the reality is that because
around is a dryad regional threat to
what is a newly formed Alliance inside
Arabia Jordan Egypt in Israel this is
becoming a backburner priority at best
for all of those nations and the idea of
this gonna create some sort of regional
conflagration in the face of what is a
Iranian military threat to a lot of
teetering regimes I think is
short-sighted and I mean moving forward
willing multiple times thinking about
the large swaths of land including parts
of Jerusalem the biggest problem is that
on the other side of Hamas which in its
Charter in 1988 suggests that both
legislature in the state visuals is top
priority
and the Palestinian Authority which in
its Charter the PLO charter 1964 prior
to Israel controlling the Old City of
Jerusalem said it is no should be
destroyed so when one side wants to
destroy gather on the other side has
offered concessions multiple times it's
very difficult the people who are
standing in that line still maybe if you
like standing that that's fine but
there's no way we're gonna get to the
back of the table realistically we're
down to the last two questions left and
right hey guys thank you that for doing
this I think our society definitely
needs
a lot more examples of people having
complex conversations so thank you
I'm wondered if you could give me some
advice on how much of my time and
attention I should spend it on things
that seem like they need solutions but
are really annoying and painful to pay
attention to versus the things that I
really like paying attention to but I
don't know maybe weren't exactly solving
these seemingly pressing problems
that's a genuinely hard question I
struggle with it I mean again it's this
comes to one of Ben's concern just a
clearly a mature notion of well-being
isn't narrowly focused on mere pleasure
right so there's many good things in
life that we know we have to struggle to
get and the struggle isn't the best we
can feel at any moment in that day and
there's Ament much much of our happiness
is in some ways retrospective you get
through the hard workout which if you
actually can experience sample in each
moment contain moments that we're back
to quite painful you know if you'd had
them for another reason you had been
very worried about the way you were
feeling just imagine what it's like to
really work out hard and if you woke up
in the morning feeling that way and you
didn't know what the hell was wrong with
you you straight to the hospital
so that the way you interpret your
extreme sensations matters and and
determines how you feel about it all but
much of our our sense of satisfaction
life is a sense of having put in the
hard work to do something that was worth
doing and and pleasure is not the only
variable that we care about and and what
I think we more and more we should care
about doing things that scale and that
that make life better for other people
and there are many many ways to play
that game the most important variable
for for determining how happy that makes
you is to dial in your intent your
intentions in a way that make it if your
intention is actually to do good in the
world and you realize you're not in
total control of the outcome that that
lived intention can be a real source of
well-being right and then and then your
sense of well-being isn't totally
dependent on the outcome you were
intending good things all the while and
you fail you still have the experience
of intending good things all the while
right and that and that has a kind of
intrinsic character psychologically
whereas if you were just a schmuck who
was constantly at odds with other
Schmucks and the world was driving you
crazy and you were trying to change it
right then you had that experience of
just your aim or the whole time and you
still failed right so I just I think
it's getting the your hands on the dial
of intention really matters but then
it's you know how you spend your time
you just have to be honest with yourself
I mean if you're what you're doing that
may in fact matter in the scheme of
things or in other people's lives makes
you miserable and you're not and you
know you have you have to sometimes step
away from it and I've had to step away
playing this game with you all you know
it's immensely satisfying to me that we
could all have a conversation like this
but it's not every moment is not filled
with pleasure and necessarily you've
heard my tone of voice but then it's not
if that's not all me broadcasting
pleasure if there's some frustration but
I think it's worth it I think it's worth
it these are all just experiments in
conversation and I think they're worth
it and we can the aggregate I get
immense satisfaction from this but but I
still have to step away I mean I like
you know is it the best use of my time
to see what all of you said about this
on Twitter tonight I'm actually I'm
making those decisions from curating my
the contents of my own consciousness a
little more circumspectly now because I
find that some even positive signals
aren't the wrong thing to be focusing on
for me and so I just which is again it's
an that it's a navigation problem for
maintenance just like where is sanity
and this
moment you just have to keep trying to
drag it on to the number of tweets I
should be noticing because I feel like I
can who did I kick out the life book you
know that is true I feel like it was I
mean the reality is that I'm not sure
why this is interesting to anyone but
then when people organize retreats like
that they hold what they call
discretionary spots for just people
outside the lottery just for people who
they're gonna want to put in and
whatever criteria they use to want to
put those people in that's that's on
them and Joseph happens to be a very
close friend and Dan was someone who I
thought could get immense value out of
the retreat and would be very good and
for spreading the word about that the
value that is to be gotten out of the
retreat so I thought that it should seem
like a no-brainer to say hey Joseph Dan
really wants to sit a retreat do you
have any response threat response left
and so it was his call
doesn't seem unethical to me but I
understand that it seems weird that you
have to post strings to go on a
meditation retreat so is there more
behind matter you there's been a lot of
guys at the mic please I gotta go to you
so I have kids you know kids right kids
all up it's great so when it comes to
free will I get it I'm completely on
board Sam with your idea that there's no
pretty well when it comes to raising
kids tell them George as' and when I'm
trying to tell him to do the right thing
and he does something stupid and then I
want to find out why he did that party
in the house is this a stupid question
he says you know why he did it because
he's 18 year old boy for when looking at
impacting his future behavior where's
the practical separation between knowing
that there's really no free will and
wanting your children to be responsible
behavior I think there are many false
assumptions about what it must mean to
think that there's no free will so I
think there's no pretty well but I think
effort is incredibly important you can't
wait a rhythm the example I use in my
book I think is if you want to learn
Chinese you can't just wait around to
see if you learn it right it's not gonna
happen to you there's a way to learn
Chinese and you have to do the things
you need to do to learn Chinese
otherwise it's not gonna happen every
skill you or system of knowledge you
could master it's like that and getting
off of drugs is like that and getting
into shape is like that and
straightening out your life in any way
that it's crooked it's like that but the
recognition that you didn't make
yourself and that you are exactly as you
are at this moment because the universe
is
it is in this moment has a flip side
which is you don't know how fully you
can be changed in the next moment by
good company and good conversations and
reading good books and you don't know
what a bu you are you are an open system
right and it's just a simple fact that
people can radically change themselves
you're not condemned to be who you were
yesterday these are my mom a huge fan of
people who are totally off this message
like if someone Jaakko willing quite the
Navy SEAL who he's like the opposite of
me in every respect right and ends it
even on this question of free will but
it me so he's all about effort and
discipline and it's all true that do all
of all he would discipline matters
disappoint has consequences
but again in each moment if you put on
Jacko's podcasts tomorrow and it changes
what you're going to do with your day by
25% and it's crucial to your happiness
you again you're not in a position to
know why it it did that that day and
didn't do it last Thursday and you're
not even in a position of know why you
turned it on really and again you're
just you're open to the universe but
again there's immense freedom in that
it's not your you can keep going in the
direction that you you want to go but as
far as what to tell kids you need a
strong sense of agency the measure of
what to tell kids is what's what to tell
anybody ultimately is what's true and
useful it's not just all that you just
don't download random truths because
some truths are I think not worth
knowing at certain moments in life right
you don't tell your eight-year-old about
all the ways in which human beings can
become diseased and die early and you
know childhood cancers on the menu and
you want to talk about that now that's
not there's there's too much reality of
certain moments and I think empowering
kids to feel like they can seize the
reins of their lives it is worth doing
something that there is no free will
maybe parental machines that are
pre-programmed to communicate
so there's no comfortable way to ever
cut this short but worth the limits of
our time here and for many of you the
limits of human bladder again it's a
it's a total honor to do this and I
mentally gratified that you have given
me the opportunity to do it by coming
out and that Ben and Eric would join me
for it and this just makes me very happy
to do this and thank you